hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen ja heute zu einem neuen video
auf meinem kanal und zwar spiele ich
zusammen mit julia ein spiel was ihr
euch unfassbar häufig mal wieder
gewünscht haben dass hier links grün
gewinnt 1 zu 0 jetzt einmal die
erklärung geben und zwar wegen wie's
geht es darum dass hewlett das sind so
klappen da kannst du zwei zu null für
mich
dies geht es darum dass wir beiden also
jule und ich hier wir befinden uns auf
einer map die relativ klein ist zum
beispiel hier gerade auf einem
hochhausdach und wir müssen uns geboxt
es geht auf jeden fall darum dass jule
und ich uns gegenseitig von dieser map
runterhauen müssen und dann können uns
beispielsweise aufschlagen und boxen und
ich kann ihnen den kopf ausgeben und
jetzt könnte ich die theoretische nehmen
nein was du willst du was drückst du
wieso fällt das ist nicht der sinn des
spiels wir können uns jetzt die box und
das ziel des spiels ist auf jeden fall
dass wir uns gegenseitig irgendwie
runterhauen das
wir haben die leiter runter geschmissen
[Musik]
haben auf jeden fall gesagt dass der
gewinner der ist der fünf runden gewinnt
nein nein nein nein
beide entschieden sich mit in den tod
gerissen
das hier ist eine ganz typische map und
zwar sind das so eisschollen da kann man
richtig zero ich bin pinguin es steht
auf jeden fall gerade 13 0 für mich hier
darf man beispielsweise nicht aus dem
ring ausfallen
du kannst mir auch kopflos oder so gebe
auf ich glaube das war auf controller
steuerung der steuerung sehr gut das war
nur leider nicht immer wie diese machen
wie die beiden beiden spaziergang jetzt
gerade durch den ring
ich hab dich traust du dich fest diese
kann ich ihnen nicht 40 letzte runde
mehr oder weniger hirn ein präparat ja
der grund hallo ich bin noch gepackt
es steht 4 zu 1 glückwunsch das könnte
jetzt schon letzten webseiten freunde da
ich habe hier einen führer werden gesagt
es geht bis fünf die frage ist kommt aus
sorry das ist erstmal warten und schauen
ob wirklich ihn zukommt
nein kommt von mir nein ich wollte dich
runterschubsen
aus ihren zu julius tragischen tod
machen wir noch eine extrarunde mit drei
gewinn runden
nein drittem ich könnte mich unendlich
klein kann ich mich hier nicht selbst
irgendwie hoch schleudern
das ist eine map da kann man relativ
easy runterfallen weil diese platten
sich teilweise steht eins zu eins wir
sind jetzt auf einer w o mein gott ich
wette das schaffst du nicht hätte es war
gut dass sehr gut was mache ich was
mache ich was tun
nein mein gott
zum abschluss sind wir jetzt wieder auf
der u-bahn map eventuelle diese runde
gewinnen sollten juli wenn jule diesem
apple gewinnen sollte dann hat sie auch
dieses extra spiel was wir hier gerade
noch machen gewonnen
du jetzt runter ich kriege ich dich denn
darunter du hast gewonnen das heißt
jetzt kommt noch ein entscheidungsspiel
die map ist wieder diese dach map ich
gehe jetzt mal direkt nach hier oben wo
diese leuchtreklame ist und ich versuche
jetzt ein over jump sidekick kopf
die anspannung war nicht so toll die
sache ist jule drückt einfach mal irgend
welche taste und dann fällt plötzlich
mal so ein klavier form immer so kann
ich dich nehmen am kopf aber ich weiß
jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht wie ich dich
da nicht vorläge wissen du staerker als
nein nein nein nein nein ich hab nicht
gerettet unentschieden
dass aber ein faires ergebnis eigentlich
an anderer stelle würden wir es heute
wieder jetzt auch beenden meine lieben
freunde wenn euch diese folge gefallen
hat dann lass gerne einen daumen hoch
bei dem video der jule
[Musik]